from the deepest parts of my heart i
want to say congratulations to you
uh you have the role of will on bel air
the highly anticipated reboot of the
fresh prince of bel air has found its
will looked at my kingdom i was finally
there i sit on my throne at the prince
of bel-air the og will smith delivered
the news directly to jabari banks who
will play the iconic leading role and
his reaction looks like his life got
flipped turned upside down you have the
role of will on bel-air
[Music]
i'm ready i'm so ready yo i'm ready to
bite down in a fun twist of faye banks
actually comes from west philadelphia
just like his character and yes his last
name is banks just like the family on
the classic sitcom hey there lord my
name is ashley banks my family and
friends want to give you some thanks
banks also tells the actor that his
father was the person who pushed him to
pursue the role so my dad sent me
actually this article about it like yo
you should really do this and i was like
dad that's not how auditions work
i can't just like yeah i want to do this
you know but two two months later
my agent sent me the call and i knew it
was right and the newcomer has pretty
much been a fan since day one i remember
in high school i begged everyone to be a
part of this thing with me and we
dressed up as the as you probably can't
see that's hilarious i love that you
know you got a a
fantastic road uh ahead of you
and i'm looking forward to being an
asset for you in this process as you
build out your life and build out your
career the new series titled bel air
will be a modern day retelling of the
classic 90s sitcom inspired by a viral
youtube trailer created by morgan cooper
you are carrying a gun on the streets
to protect yourself
[Music]
i've done my best will
but it's time for a change
you're going to bel air
to live with your uncle and your auntie
bellaire
out of all places this is a second
chance wheel
the show will lean into the series
original premise following will's
complicated journey from the streets of
west philadelphia to the gated mansions
of bel air you got your own pool in here
and a tennis court too
yo that's better than a love boat this
boy gonna be maxing and relaxing however
the peacock series will dive deeper into
the inherent conflicts emotions and
biases that were impossible to fully
explore in a 30-minute sitcom format
while still delivering swagger and nods
to the original show this is going to be
wild
of course this comes after the og cast
reunited in 2020 during an hbo max
special you welcome will
now this is a story all about how my
life got flipped turned upside down and
i'd like to take a minute just sit right
there i'll tell you how i became
this really was the tv reunion that we
needed in 2020 oh people are reacting
with so much love and tears
and laughter
and size and excitement okay i'll start
with daphne what has the
reaction been like for you
like a big hug
it's been a wonderful way to share a
family reunion in this time where we
really need family reunions and karen it
was so emotional though i mean i i
didn't come with tissues but i had to
get some how was it for you oh i mean a
complete emotional rollercoaster when we
did it when we met it just blood all
over again so much emotion so i am so
honored to have been a part of something
that has
that has touched people so deeply and
has reached people and lasted and
carried on generation after generation